Oh as there's six of us and there's
seven Thrones whose was that for
well whoever it is I'm going to love them
no matter what because they're an
automatic part of the family as far as I
know Mike Adams not going to be in the
second Shazam because the idea is that
they want to go and do a standalone
black out of moving first and then like
this is only good country to do a third
Shazam and the second black Adam kind of like that yeah that's where we would
seize them
he's like loads of it back for Captain
Marvel is a right like black
doppelgangers right there like during
the evil to win to who I am
so that's happy like the final battle if
we do that in the second movie that
murder we go after that I know it would
just be able to be it just a sitting
around video games but the third one
be very boring or not I'm a video game
player so yeah I think that's I think
that's the idea is that we but just to
pace it out however hi everyone happy
Comic Con week so we finally have
Zachary Levi spilling some of the tea on
what's going on behind the scenes with
the grand plan is for Shazam vs. Black
Adam pretty much in line with what I was
thinking a couple weeks ago when we got
some of the deleted scenes hinting at
Black Adam within the universe so we'll
break it all down the rock was also
talking about the Black Adam movie at
the recent premiere of his fast and
furious spin-off movie so I'll explain
what he said about it - because it's
comic-con week we'll still do that IMAX
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Shazam or Black Adam moment on the video because of the joke does a Qui
leave I just made I'm going to call it now
the post credit scene for the Shazam vs.
Black Adam movie it's just going to be them playing video games together like Mortal
Kombat I'm bleeding out and I need you
they had a funny moment like that during
the Shazam movie right after Billy got
his powers where he and Freddie are
playing video games together while he's
in Shazam form just imagine the most
hooked out version of the rock sitting
next to him while he's in Shazam form
just going at each other in some crazy
fighting game listening to him talk
about that it's a little bit clearer now
why they actually deleted this scene
from the movie because originally this
scene would have happened at the very
end of the film when they come back to
the rock of eternity they sit down and
if we would have seen this in the
theater we would have naturally just
assumed they're trying to tease Black
Adam in the next movie
when Zachary Levi is telling us that's
not the case no he's coming it's going to
be a big deal but not till a little bit
later but what does this timeline mean
for the plot of the Black Adam movie in
the plot of the Shazam sequel both of
which they're probably going to start
shooting next year we knows they're
shooting the Black Adam movie next year
and we'll see that during 2021 we know
that they greenlit the Shazam sequel so
we know that they're making it but they
haven't said exactly when they're going to
start shooting I'm assuming sometime
next year after they shoot the Black
Adam movie based on what he's saying and what the rock has been saying it sounds
like the Black Adam movie
going to jump back and forth between
present day in the past to tell his
origin story in how he became teth-adam
using the version of his origin story
that they established her in the Shazam
movie but they were vague enough with
that that they can actually play with it
quite a bit during the blackout of movie
like he took revenge on man by
unleashing the seven deadly sins but why
did he do that
who is he fighting who's the villain of
that movie going to be who's worse than
Black Adam the way that they set him up
is that his family is killed when he was
young the council of wizards at that
time are growing weaker with age and
they choose him as successor to guard
the world against the seven deadly sins
keeping them contained in the rock of
eternity the secret that they don't tell
you during the Shazam movie though is
that their other job and this would have
been black Adams other job before he
bailed on it and turned on mankind is
protecting the earth lands from the
other seven realms of magic so there's
seven different realms of magic they're
all just super crazy they'll explore
them in the Shazam sequel we'll learn
why they're so dangerous and why it's so
important to keep them separated but way
back when Black Adam got his powers
originally that would have been one of
his jobs - watching that magical
PowerPoint presentation that the wizard
gives Billy we know that Black Adam at
some point succumbs to his rage in
exacts his revenge on the people of the
world by releasing the seven deadly sins
there was another deleted scene that I
did a video about last week where we
learned that the wizard then tried to go
subdue Black Adam with what power he had
left because they'd just given Black
Adam some of their powers so they're
weaker than they would have been the
seven deadly sins used that opportunity
to poison the minds of the other wizards
on the council causing a big civil war
which they eventually begin to recapture
the sins but not before some of the
Wizards turn on each other kill each
other and then themselves the deleted
scene implies some really hardcore
moments in these flashbacks oh I don't
know how they're going to tune that for the
Black Adam movie but presumably we'll
see a version of that in flashbacks the
wizard Shazam eventually traps Black
Adam for all eternity using his greatest
spells that's right this is and family
the Shazam Lee can cast spells just like
any other big magic users Zatanna
Constantine dr. fate within the DC
Universe
they just don't know how to do it yet
they haven't learned how to use all
their abilities
then over the next several hundred years
he captures the rest of the seven deadly
sins and traps them in the rock of
eternity in that orb that you see during
the movie then spends the next several
hundred years or however long looking
for another champion to take his place
until you get to that scene at the
beginning of the movie with dr. sivana
showing up we know mr. mind is going to be
the main villain or one of the main
villains of the Shazam sequel as he
tries to use dr. sivana to take control
of the seven realms of magic fun fact
mr. mind is actually from the magic
lands he's from the wild lands which are
populated with a bunch of talking
animals including talky tawny the tiger
in the classic Captain Marvel Shazam
comics it was just a regular Tiger but
in the new DC rebirth Shazam comic book
he's an actual tiger that walks around
on two legs and talks like a human so
I'm assuming that he's going to show up
during this Shazam sequel they still
haven't said anything about who the main
villain of the blackout of movie is
going to be deep cut if you saw the rock
in the mummy movies and then saw
Scorpion King you know that in the mummy
movies he's this ancient evil warrior
king that was turned into a giant
scorpion in present day by the gods but
he started out as more of an antihero in
the villain of his Scorpion King origin
movie was a way worse warlord who killed
his family and he became this reluctant
hero of the people until he was forced
to make a deal with the devil so to
speak so do not be surprised if you see
a similar type of villain in the Black
Adam movie someone terrible enough that
it feels justified that black Adam
releases the seven deadly sins on him as
revenge by the end of that movie and
then also at the end of the movie set up
his plot in present-day getting ready to
face off with the Shazam family aka the
Shazam Lee as there's six of us and
there's seven Thrones whose was that for
so tentative timeline for all these
movies Black Adam movie is next that'll
probably be 2021 Shazam - right after
that / Jack where you Levi Black Adam
showing up in the post credits for that
then either Shazam 3 Shazam vs. Black
Adam two years after that in 2023 or if
the Black Adam movie does gangbusters
huge numbers maybe they fast-tracked
Black Adam - in 2023 in den do Shazam
vs. Black Adam the year after that hard
to say whether or not Warner Brothers
would want to release - Shazam movies in
the same year counting black Adams of
Shazam movie but let me know in the
comments who do you want the villain of
the Black Adam movie to be they could
pull all kinds of deep cuts from the
comics Vandal Savage Felix Faust more
drew Morgan la Fey clarion near on mr.
mind is even supposed to be pretty
ancient so they could use him as well
but I do like the idea of Vandal Savage
versus black Adam because Vandal Savage
is functionally immortal he has instant
tissue regeneration so it doesn't really
matter how powerful black Adam is he
could pound Vandal Savage into the
ground and he would regenerate
immediately but after Shazam phases
black Adam
PI by that time Warner Brothers will be
ready to try another Justice League film
with Shazam on the team maybe with JJ
Abrams if everything goes well because
Warner Brothers just paid his company a
half a billion dollars to exclusively
develop content for Warner Brothers both
movies and TV shows so don't be
surprised if you see JJ Abrams doing a
couple big DC movies in the next several
years but if we're talking about the
next Justice League film that's like
2024 2025 so five six years sounds like
enough time for the dust to settle from
the last Justice League movie just to
put that into perspective they didn't
even wait that long to reboot spider-man
with Tom Holland but it's Comic Con week it's time to go crazy there's going to be
so much cool stuff dropping this week
I'll do as many videos as I can but
leave all your requests in the comments
below
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see all the Comic Con
videos when I post them but click here
for my spider-man far from home
Fantastic Four Easter Egg video and
click here to watch Chris Hemsworth
waste Matt Damon in real life in and for a
guardians 3 update
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay awesome, and I'll see you guys tonight!